hello and welcome to dw's international
reporters magazine world stories with me
Leila ha Rock coming up on today's show
young Bulgarians are using Facebook to
learn more about their country's
communist past and in Bangladesh they're
benefiting from garbage and how a
Chilean NGO is trying to save the bees
that and more just ahead but we kick off
in Cambodia when you think of coconuts
you probably imagine tropical cocktails
exotic curries and nourishing skin
creams but what about fuel in Cambodia
coconuts are used in almost every meal
so they're discarded shells are a common
waste product but one company has found
good use for them as an environmentally
friendly alternative to charcoal
producing conventional charcoal requires
cutting down trees and that's
devastating the countries for us so will
the future be powered by coconuts care
sinks rights had caught a glimpse of
things to come Len is out with his whole
family in there took took he makes the
rounds of Phnom Penh's markets he's
collecting coconut shells coconut flakes
are an ingredient in many Cambodian
dishes so there are a lot of shells left
over at the markets Len can earn money
with them
a factory on the outskirts of Panem pen
is willing to pay for coconut shells
here they're not waste there are raw
material the idea is to provide Cambodia
with an environmental friendly product
since the first station is a big issue
here in Cambodia so our charcoal is a
completely recycled organic waste so we
don't cut any trees to produce struggle
Cambodians use a lot of wood for
construction furniture making and for
fuel even large textile factories like
this one use wood as an energy source
the storage area is fully stocked jeans
production for overseas contractors can
swallow up entire forests Cambodia's
woodlands have shrunk by about twenty
percent over the past ten years there's
hardly any rain forest left at all no
trees have to be felled for the coconut
shells chopped into manageable size they
form the basic material for green
briquettes they also create jobs this
factory now has 15 permanent employees
the finely chopped shells are packed
into an oven and set alight the factory
workers develop this method themselves
this comes from a cooking soul it was
the cooking so working with a wood
pellets and we had upscaled it to try
the coconut shell so it's a very
innovative idea and I think we are the
only ones that have this in the world
after two hours at 800 degrees Celsius
the 45 kilos of shells have been reduced
to 10 kilos of charcoal
this is ground-up fine and pressed into
green briquettes charcoal without coal
the factory sells its fuel to
restaurants and private customers who
use it mainly for cooking
Cambodia numbers among the world's
poorest countries this street barber
tries to attract customers with music
simple street restaurants line the
sidewalks they all use charcoal it's
always been the cheapest fuel
this japanese BBQ restaurant has
switched from conventional charcoal to
the green briquets they cost the same
and don't give off nearly as much smoke
the factory needs more customers like
this one the proprietor likes the
briquettes so much he's put up an
advertisement for them I'm sorry I found
it up I'm very surprised yeah product
chuckles oh yes I oh very surprising but
as I want to use it sorry I use its
eco-friendly very important more and
more small shops are also discovering
the benefits of the green briquets this
shop owner has been selling them and
already ordered more
well I'd the green briquettes burn
longer than charcoal and they don't give
off so many sparks they sell quite well
the factory needs more customers it's up
to the promotion team to win them over
every morning took trucks drive in from
the country loaded with charcoal quite
often made from timber illegally cut in
cambodia's last remaining rain forests
come by and SIA says the promoter the
factory's right around the corner the
boys from the country have never seen
briquettes like these before
look like they look really odd maybe we
could try them sometime but they have no
time to drop by the factory they have
customers waiting for delivery these
people are poor they have no other way
to earn their money even if they do
worry about the environment of all
18,000 I mean it's not easy getting a
new product accepted by a market rooted
in tradition the green briquettes
factory was started by French
nongovernmental organizations in 2010
now it's up to industrial engineer kalo
talamanca of spain to make it profitable
I started working this factory six
months ago in a July 2011 and the last
six months we succeeded to increase our
sales from an average of two Tom's /
months to over 8 tons per month and to
reduce the cost but sustainability is
still a long way to go the factory will
have to sell twice as much to turn a
profit but word about the green
briquettes is spreading among customers
and suppliers both and they're realizing
that throwing away coconut shells means
throwing away a good source of cheap
clean energy next we had to Bulgaria for
nearly half a century the country was
firmly communist until the collapse of
the Eastern Bloc and the coming of
democracy in 1990 now more than two
decades later some Bulgarians are
developing a keen interest in the
country's recent past and they've chosen
an up-to-date way to share their
memories in the digital age we've all
become used to posting pictures on our
Facebook pages to share our personal
story with our friends and family here
are a couple of impressions from my own
recent past in West Africa Molly but now
let's get back to those vulgarians a
group of young people who have set up a
Facebook page with a difference Nova TVs
Nina dimitrova takes a look online
these snapshots taken in the 1960s and
70s provide rare glimpses of what life
was like in Bulgaria when it was a
communist state the miss Varna 1965
beauty contest factory workers packaging
cigarettes women working in the merits
of bottling and canning factory in the
town of Pazuzu all these images and more
have been collected by three men the
youngest is 18 year old gurgi from the
city of stara zagora Bethenny the chasm
chesley these photos we wanted to show
what the towns cities and countryside
looked like back then we wanted to show
the athletes actors musicians and
singers who lived in the people's
republic of bulgaria some of them are
still living today the page on an
internet site was launched just over a
year ago and it quickly became popular
most of the fans are between 34 and 44
some of them live in Bulgaria but the
page is also a favorite with Bulgarians
who live in the u.s. the UK Spain and
Germany the page has more than 10,000
photos collated into more than 100
albums
hasn't it we find the photos on Barry's
internet sites that have some connection
to the topic we also use photos from
albums that were published before 1989
but they're hard to find we have our own
archive and we also use materials from
old newspapers it's both some of the
photos were provided by fans of our
facebook page that just continued with
staff in Venice dynasty the page also
elicits discussion and criticism of the
former communist regime ports the
darkness in people some people say we're
communists but that's ridiculous trying
to link an 18 year old boy to the
communist regime is absolute nonsense
absolutely people like that are not
interested in commenting on the photos
they just want to annoy and provoke
people that there are the important of
course difficulty k
gurgi says the photos and comments
enable him and other young Bulgarians to
find out more about their country's past
Methos that instead the cousin the idea
of the page is to show how people lived
during that time and what their everyday
lives were like without any political
agenda our page doesn't aim to interfere
with evaluate or comment on politics we
just want to show how people live
and we turn to Jordan out to meet a
young man who has triumphed against all
the odds born in one of jordan's poorer
regions the talented science students
had has made it through university
winning accolades and a host of
international prizes in the process he
has the full support of his professors
for his latest invention an innovation
that could transform the lives of the
country's small-scale farmers or your
TV's why the hammer caught up with him
abdul rahman al zircon is a university
student with a passion for both hard
work and knowledge it's a combination
that's helped him develop a new
irrigation technology it's cheap and it
works in freezing temperatures shot I
could be a model of mahalia i entered
local and international competitions and
took part in the Intel International
Science and Engineering Fair twice and I
want a prize and I'm also doesn't look a
minute Abdullah at the time I was
working on refining my project with
financial support from a major research
fund I entered a competition in the u.s.
in 2008 and took fourth place then in
2010 I was granted a patent for my
invention here in Jordan that I BF n
wash it off Azarcon grew up in jordan's
to fela governor the area of the country
with the worst poverty and unemployment
he studies at the Turf fila technical
university where he's won the support
and encouragement of his teachers
bunnell you might as well I focused on
my objective I worked hard and stayed
the course until I achieved it determine
he persevered and experimented trial and
error our disciplines he's been teaching
himself since he was about twelve the
teachers and lecturers of the tefila
Technical University supported the
research and development process right
up to his application for a patent
had that nikhat Jordan has a semi-arid
Mediterranean climate but at higher
elevations it can freeze a reliable
system for transporting and distributing
warm water was just what was needed the
system costs only around one hundred and
fifty euros purchased directly from
under Rahman an investment quickly
recoup tin the produce it saves from
frost damage leonel Votolato Fukushima
Reginald Kira's are not just found on
the battlefield but also in the sciences
as this young Jordanian man Abdur Rahman
of zircon hash aromatic amine
shutterstock he became one of the most
prominent names in the field in 2012 we
congratulate him and his country Jordan
man well honey and indeed good luck to
him now to the Bay of Bengal chittagong
the second most populous city in
Bangladesh and one of the fastest
growing in the world is home to over two
million people and some of the country's
largest companies the city generates so
much rubbish the garbage piles up faster
than it can be taken away and instead of
despairing the local authorities have
come up with an idea designed not only
to provide an incentive to clean up the
streets but also took benefit nearby
farmers and provide an income for the
city etv chocolate on reports
as chittagong spa pule ation grows so do
the mountains of garbage it produces it
piles up in various places polluting the
environment and leading the city a mess
the chittagong city corporation took the
initiative to solve the problem they
started by bringing all the city's
garbage to the ananda bazar area of
Halla she har
intership d Hamas tomoya a dumping
pleaser Phyllis about 1800 chittagong
city corporation workers known as shay
back dump the garbage here in three
shifts around the clock a book working
to clean up the city cuando NC
Department a chakra
much of the garbages household trash
every day about 700 tons of rubbish pile
up here
exactly I debris attacked us to pocket
it was a huge amount to consider cut
portions in the city corporation began
looking for a way to use it as a
resource that would make money of it
that it's worth it and so they built
this garbage treatment plant at the gate
bottom through a garbage treatment
blender automating the airport exquisite
first we compress it to remove the fiber
very good the process produces fiber and
dust have a big one for it that's
beautiful that's the gambler we use the
dust in compost we are the best number
lucky fo nautica so we also get some
straw like materials that we used me
play would we look at the Umbra you're
gonna fire to look up to see the
chittagong city corporation also uses
the trash to make fuel and fertilizer
the fertilizer is in demand for use in
agriculture at the same time the garbage
is taken off the streets where it might
otherwise have caused disease
jovanna bully aisha appliqué armour sha
bebe no Donna Brooks is Tito the germs
are dangerous if allowed to breed they
can cause many types of illnesses take
aspirin of the kids so what we're trying
to do is isolate them but composites am
i doing that we can turn them to our
advantage by making them into compost
fertilizer by elegant all gotten burrito
I'm at the Roxy staccato
inspired by the success of its first
garbage treatment plant the chittagong
city corporation is planning more
projects along the same lines
dc's haven't got a we are sending a
request to the mayor for a big piece of
land outside the city near pitanga sea
beach where we can dump the garbage and
relocate the plants as well Benson
around affordable wickellia all day but
we were thinking about doing this on a
large scale production OJT body she'd
met interval hypocrisy commercial
mudassar pseudo choreographer calculated
amber eternity we have several projects
in the pipeline horrible at master had
too heavy we are considering trying to
grow mushrooms in a future at the moment
we are experimenting trying to produce
fish food at our garbage treatment plant
whether with the word a shape or the
commander needs eating with it projects
like this can go a long way toward
protecting the environment and public
health as well garbage can be a resource
and a source of revenue
the chittagong city corporation has
already set a shining example now most
people associate bees with honey what's
less commonly known is that without them
we humans would have to do without all
kinds of everyday necessities bees play
a crucial role in pollination for many
plants plans that we eat and plans that
we use to produce clothing but for years
now the population of bees worldwide has
been a sharp decline fewer bees means
less food and less food means higher
prices now a group of Chilean
specialists has formed an organization
to raise awareness of the problem and
try to tackle it at the source and as
you see V TVs milena Rodriguez Soares
shows us we could all feel a sting if
these don't make a comeback I'll very
instant Albert Einstein once said if
bees disappeared from the surface of the
earth humans would have no more than
four years to live worry about it said
it that may sound exaggerated even an
alarmist but in fact a huge proportion
of the food consumed by humans would not
exist without the pollinating function
of bees many everyday products like milk
cotton and even many common painkillers
depend on these insects de cabeza
depending ingram marie de el trabajo de
tous insectos the situation is swiftly
turning critical with an estimated
one-third of the world's bees
disappearing every year for Daniel and
the proportion appears to be rising not
fooling that's how he has c5 that can be
something what I press ENTER blessing
what rahay pro is a Chilean company
dedicated to promoting sustainable
beekeeping specialists from the company
formed in NGO to do something about the
bees decline nobody haven't done I'm
Antonio baghban veloute I'm managing
director of the NGO plan B it was
founded to address the need for a
functioning model for breeding bees we
started a tackle Kimbo region a
wholly-owned problema we knew that the
beekeepers there were collecting all the
honey from their hives they were also
fortifying the bees food with dietary
supplements that ended up weakening the
hives and that led to the beekeepers
products having to be subsidized Lana
here so Mojave are adequate in about 40
people are working in the NGOs various
areas now education and nutrition for
example we're also working on ways to
optimize production I'm improving the
use of water ethological balance and
handling of waste Emily manejo de
Richelieu
as I sing quietly yella we will do it
I've been keeping bees for five years
now when I started out beekeeping
already had some big problems the most
urgent one right now is the climate it
hasn't rained March and we've had to
irrigate a lot to stop the blossoms
dying another problem is pesticides lots
of pesticides are used in farming it's
gotten really bad the NGO is active in
an environment that's out of reach of
most beekeepers the city lovella kosaki
it educates children about what needs
bees have and how useful they really are
for all of us including children than
sec LOL ok well it's all of an ethnicity
/ train but I the nonprofit organization
is placing great hope in the younger
generation it wants to create a shift in
awareness and encourage people to
implement measures to protect bees in
the short time it's existed Plan B has
come up against many obstacles they
haven't been easy to deal with but the
group's members are undeterred they're
tackling the problem from various angles
and areas like education distribution
and research and by offering advice
through counseling programs control a
map we've received no support because
our problems are associated with mines
mobile phone antennas and pour water
utilization in this country all our
proposed projects have been rejected we
need to clarify the problem even if we
already have a guy you thought I meeting
everybody I'd say our country is among
the world leaders for consumption per
capita that makes us concentrate on
improving things that don't necessarily
harmonize with the needs of our country
we're not opposed to industrial
production no but if you look at the
action that the government takes you'll
see it does not go hand-in-hand with
improving people's lives love you
um problema muchas veces and not among
way danger of bees vanishing from the
earth needs to be taken more seriously
nearly fifty percent of all the bee
colonies worldwide have died out in the
past six years alone else in cuenta por
ciento de la con minas an evil mondial
es por año de vita la importancia la la
the NGO plan b is concentrating on
finding our causes and on offering
practical solutions be honest i as well
as on opening the world's eyes to the
effects of human greed on this planet
solos en cuanto it's a question of
survival la hora hina de la vida humana
en nuestro planeta and with that report
we've come to the end of this edition
thanks so much for watching to let us
know what you think about the program
post a message on our Facebook page look
for us under DW english for now here are
this week's pics of the world see you
next time